welcome to this video playing routine
houghton I don't know never played the
skype okay Queens gambit I guess this
laughs okay let's play the the standard
main line for a change and maybe I can
do something different not only for this
i recently saw in one of John
Bartholomew's videos never thought that
this would give white much or much maybe
just nothing but it's maybe still worth
playing once in a while okay getting the
pong back at least the problem of the
whole line for wide is that this night
here on HS is simply not a great piece
you will lose time to get it back into
play or taking yeah I don't know it's
not not a line that I really know much
about but one thing is pretty clear if I
manage with white 22 to do something
against c5 wait maybe I should really do
this quickly get the night to be 3 or
only allow him to play c5 under less
favorable circumstances then I should be
quite okay with white okay I can tick
and then might be three yeah maybe this
is a little something nothing great but
I'm certainly a little bit better on the
queenside okay I can take now and Queen
B 5 just grabbing stuff maybe 95 is also
a useful move
that's actually even better yeah just
irritating like a little bit if you
moves night d70s to reckon with 96 yeah
and here i have night c4 stairs some
other way to play that's ok just putting
pressure on the e5 pawn and what I would
really love to play is e 4r e 4 and
possibly f3 yeah this kind of thing
limiting the knight on f6 re4 f3 bishop
you three this would be fantastic if I
get this in the system this would be
really good trying to prepare that check
we have queen 27 quincy for and yeah I
have my doubt that it's really that good
but I should have seen it of course
check first the first problem is there's
a five I mean then I will check his bill
is no ideas I'm threatening to retreat
the night let's do that and I overlooked
the move Bishop age too but coming
reason yeah it's true near the challenge
I can can ignore but yeah it was really
not working out a piece up it's um the
thing is this is all depends on c5 black
has to get in c5 somehow under under
good circumstances and the way it had
panned out what I thought would be quite
nice with those nights here they both
put some pressure on a hive but it's
nothing super exciting and then he all
of a sudden here he unleashed this
this move I thought yet to do something
something conservative yeah maybe age
six even because Bishop g5 is kind of a
threat something like this and then I
thought this is setup him Bishop here
then the the blue the pony is very
important it controls very important
glands 95 is not possible and note that
he's got he's got this night still back
and it's not so easy to put it into the
game if he goes knight c6 for example
there's always this not this thing the
Queen looking at the rook and it's not
so this is not a very nice position like
it's just sitting there and cannot do
very much also note that this weakness
is not going away I'm even in a minor
piece and game it would be a big problem
computer is giving 0.74 white so already
is something quite substantial I think
he probably I don't know around here
maybe he needs to do something something
more precise computer wants to play this
move which is difficult to do for a
human because it sort of Hanks this rook
but yeah I can sleep like before I have
to be honest yeah yeah I'm already a
little bit better nothing decides it but
it is nice for wine yeah so they didn't
need to lose that quickly okay well
thanks for watching